he's a wonderful presence johnny is is
one of the most gifted actors we have he
is
a truly gifted
character actor that
is trapped in a leaning man's body he's
there's no one else like him and he's um
to add on top of that to the unfairness
and torture of that he's also a
wonderful person
wonderful human being and um and i'm
could not have asked for a better
co-star
our experiences as women are as varied
and nuanced and
layered as
as men and and unfortunately when we
look at how we're portrayed and art and
we look at how we're portrayed in movies
which are supposed to be a
representation of life
there's a deficit a cruel deficit of the
varying scope of variety and nuance
available to characters that are
supposed to be portraying women
in the vast
variety of things that we are you opened
up to l recently about you know being
married what's your favorite thing about
being there they always say i opened up
because i
i said i want because i confirmed i said
yes i am um i said i'm happily married
woman and i'll say it again i'm a
happily married woman and again if
that's the version of opening up then
that's it i'm sorry tonight
amber heard
but uh but yes i said i'm very happy i
don't have social media so i don't i
don't know but i do i am aware that it
is happening i'm aware of this
phenomenon and i think it's really
interesting to look at how it's
affecting especially younger younger
girls um
that are raised in a in a culture where
this is just
a
a part of their everyday life is this
superficial representation
and promotion of themselves in this way
um but for me i think
with my life i think it's the most
precious thing i can have is privacy and
and
and so i don't
i don't have
any reason or desire to want to
put it out there nothing but but but i
understand a lot of people
do and why they would you know a lot of
people um find ways to do it
you know for for
for good and to control their the
representations of themselves which i
think actors typically or celebrities
typically have not had control over for
a long time i'm really excited to be 30.
i think it's
you know your 20s are i feel like when i
ask women this often
my friends say that that that it's the
one some of the hardest years of the 20s
i don't know who set the standard that
that's supposed to be the most fun but i
think i've i've lived enough life in my
20s i'm looking forward to
i don't know i'm looking forward to this
new kind of chapter if you want to look
at it that way i'm excited to be you
know even more of a woman that's what it
feels like violence against women is an
issue that transcends all
social economic geographic boundaries
everyone is affected it's a global issue
and it's an issue that has
been relegated mostly to the private
sector it's largely unspoken about
underrepresented under-reported it is
internationally the most under-reported
crime it affects uh women uh it at a
disproportionate level and it's it does
so silently and unless we raise
awareness and talk about it and bring it
to light we can't change the system it
maintains the silence you know we can't
change it unless we talk about it and
it's really easy to not change it if we
don't see
the faces we don't see who our rules our
systems are hurting it's an issue
that
happens
predominantly behind closed doors
violence against women is an unseen
thing even economic violence against
women it's an unseen thing and us women
are strong and we endure and we have a
lot of stuff to do in our life so if we
stopped and talked about it and and
cried every single time
an injustice befell us we would have no
time in the day
and so here we are enduring and
surviving almost too much and i want to
just be one of the many many voices
right now of women of countless women
who are standing up and saying enough is
enough hear me too
yes me too
time's up
you